what happens when nearly 50,000 people
make a gift to Carnegie Mellon during
the decade of the inspire innovation
campaign you surpass a 1 billion dollar
goal by almost two hundred million
dollars and transform an institution
big-time new permanently endowed funds
support 30 faculty positions and 90
graduate fellowships in such diverse
fields as life sciences robotics in the
arts more than 200 new undergraduate
scholarship funds were permanently
endowed and nearly 100 million dollars
went to undergraduate financial aid
campaign gifts support research
initiatives that can pioneer solutions
to important global problems while new
programs enrich a curriculum that helped
make CMU students highly sought after by
the world's most innovative companies
the stunning new gates and Hillman
centers house computer science and
future generation technologies nearby
sits a hub of collaborative innovation
between technology industries and
university scholars where
experimentation flourishes and new
businesses come to life another new
facility Scott Hall will provide space
for expanded programs in energy
innovation biomedical engineering and
nanotechnology an ambitious expansion of
student exercise and performance
facilities is on the drawing board many
older spaces were refurbished and
repurposed with gifts from science labs
to athletic fields and more than 800
million dollars in additional program
support is at work in spaces old and new
our business school with a backing of
alumnus David Tepper has the opportunity
to once again rewrite the book on
management education benefiting new
generations of students executives and
entrepreneurs the Heinz endowments made
possible a unique combination of
programs in a single Hines College that
builds new skills for analyzing big data
implementing socio economic policy
change
and guiding the development of a global
economy bill d-trix magnificent
endowment gift provides a permanent and
growing source of financial flexibility
annual gifts also remain a major source
of vital financial flexibility and
broad-based giving grew steadily during
the campaign we are a young and
energetic University hard at work in
seeking partnerships worldwide as we
celebrate the success of the inspire
innovation campaign we're confident and
ready for emerging challenges today we
are standing on a new springboard for
action